As americans buy millions of new smartphones
so too do we throw old models into the garbage.
With them may go old messages but also all sorts
of valuable materials used in the phones. Rare
earth minerals. At the same time we dutifully
separate glass and paper in our blue recycling
bins despite the fact that much of what we
put out at the curbside actually has little
resale or reuse value and it costs our local
government scarce funds to collect. Here's why:
In 2017 China, once the most common destination,
closed its doors to foreign recyclables. Cities
must pay now to have recyclables taken
off their hands. And the contents of
those virtuous blue bins — often negative.
That's why many cities have halted recycling
altogether. We need to rethink recycling as a
sort of trash mine. Separate the valuable stuff
and stop spending scarce post-pandemic public
dollars to collect stuff we actually have to pay
to get rid of. Let's get smart about recycling.
Do you think recycling still makes sense?
Let us know in our poll. Also let us know what
other topics you want our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like and subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.